we are live live reaction from three man
oh man Xbox Microsoft press conference
we just came out to spot oh man it so
much to talk about we got Lord Saint
over in the building TI cg fam the iron
boy podcast Lord sin we just saw this
conference what are you feeling what are
your overall the presses of the Xbox
Microsoft Office we wanted a roadmap and
I think we got what we saw a very solid
foundation to what's looking to be a
promising house with all these things
that we're gonna dive into you know I'd
say overall I well I'll give my overall
score later but they may have showed
promise even if it might not immediately
be the games we want
they are absolutely listening they're
not just reacting they're taking the
foot forward how much I think you could
have said it better but set yourself I
mean at the end of the day we knew the
stakes coming in yes right we knew the
stakes company we felt what marks I've
had to deliver I mean I I'm very
pessimistic you know I'm a sick person
I'm realistic you're pessimistic well I
would listen people make all these
claims and it's like always ever get the
marketing the buzzwords all that good
stuff I accept with my expectations
I knew realistically what maybe they can
do and I was hoping for some surprises
man we got three guys a surprise okay
man okay so I mean I think we have to
start with the biggest thing which in my
opinion was the megaton not one not two
not three not four but five new studio
they doubled their output just like that
absolutely so what's the file let's
break it down so first off we have the
initiative now this is an acquisition
this is a new team that they're starting
what's funny is I thought the initiative
was the neighbor the whole day this is a
bold new plan we're giving you the plan
for how we play down no the initiative
led by their Darrell Gallagher there was
much speculation the previous month
he was added to the Microsoft Studios
and the executive leadership team house
he's gonna head up the studio he work on
Tomb Raider
worked on call duty at night division Oh
big experience yeah next one big
surprise but a welcome one undead labs
can I can I jump on this warship I look
shout out the fogey the crew jeff strain
listen man i'm a huge state of the
campaign fan majority no it's not the
Lord's rien PAX East we killed it up
with them and our only thing was that
look why wasn't that game given
dedicated service while I was walking
behind the triple-eight treatment and to
see them now in house and Microsoft make
the commitment right no more double a
this you know let's just go all the way
with it cuz and it also gives me
confidence for the future of the
franchise state indicate three now what
happens now exactly the cated servers
that whole big so huge with that well we
got it
so up next and this one probably one of
the few announcements that sort of weeks
before in playground games and
officially announced their in house not
that's playground games is actually two
studios because we have the very
talented Forza horizon team I mean they
made the highest-rated game on xbox the
highest will the highest-rated expensive
so why not bring them in the second team
we know they're working on an open-world
RPG we don't think it's awesome
now this next one if you heard a holler
if you listened back into the conference
there was a bit of a scream going on
Ninja Theory mmm
ninja food ok saw that coming please
know that's fantastic
they made hell blade which fantastic
nominal game but there is a relationship
going back several years like kung foo
chaos that was an OG xbox title not a
lot of people knew about it you know and
this is this is a very talented
developer they've always made different
games heavenly soul yes very very
different and they've actually released
a video explaining why they were okay
with Microsoft bringing them into the
fold
write that down they're gonna blank
checks on development baby basically
basically they didn't want to be oh
you're gonna be turned into a game
studio machine you know we're just gonna
crank stuff out nope these are the
projects we want to make this is what
we're gonna make Microsoft gives them
kitano control of their ways they they
our ties and their creative vision let
me jump in on that that's huge
the use of it for two reasons because I
look at Microsoft and I look at the
history and I look at things like one
gene and what happened with you know
them leaving and trying to create
destiny and I'm not trying to knock
Microsoft it's just that we know
sometimes based on the past history
they've had a hands-on approach with
those studios and kind of get mini ball
and to see that creative control
released and relinquish and give them
back to the studio and say hey here's
the blank check cut it you deliver the
product and take as much time as you
need
that's a huge culture shift yes it's not
very indicative of what's going on okay
you know what we got money makers
elsewhere make what you want me
fantastic last but not least compulsion
games maybe the least known of the bunch
they made we happy few it's coming out
and it's actually going to be getting
that narrative mode that everyone really
really wanted when we saw that teaser
back in 2016 and then the early access
came out people like wait this is just a
survival game what's going on but hey it
looks like we're actually gonna get that
creepy Bioshock s story I'm down let's
see what they can do listen I'm with
that I mean I'm definitely with that and
I shout out to shout out to Phil for
like I like how they did that segment
visually yes like like they had each
segment and then you thought it was only
two and then another one and then they
didn't leave room right and they were
doing the segment's it took up the whole
screen and then they sort of folded back
inside wait there's room for one more
yes oh wait there's room for another
dude oh good lord there's room for
another one that was lit the way they
did that I thought again and we're gonna
get into the end of the show right but I
felt they're taking a page and learning
from Sony yes one thing Sony guys are
calling pro they know how to present
they know how to get the crowd right you
know how to get their fan base
energized you know I mean so to see
Microsoft now instead of just suits
coming on stage all these semi fake
let's plays hey Jimmy go over there and
we don't wanna see what you guys have
been store and also get the fanbase
excited by just hitting the ground
running game game game game games
exactly what you got
so next what we've got gears okay Holly
go and redeemed Holly go there were
three your egg they got dressed Holly
gone you got dragged through the mud on
that but hey you are redeemed there were
three gears games that first
announcement I think took us all a
little bit by surprise
yeah the phone pop joint okay
funkopop mobile up okay all right all
right all right all right
it's fine whatever just to give me my
proper gears next we got gears tactics
yeah I got two things say about this
one's really good ones really okay so
got my hollow this one it's conga its
gears of war meets ex-con and that's
beautiful set before the first game I
think it's 17 years before you get to
customize your squad turn-based combat
mood I love it I love it I love it go
however the way that they announced this
thing is leading some understandably to
believe that it's a PC only title that
better not be true that bad enough and
if it is that needs to be rectified we
need to see this come to Xbox
XCOM and XCOM - they're on Xbox they're
on ps4 and they run great mm-hmm there
is no excuse I don't want to hear it
writing it over and I think that you
can't have an exclusive DC title on the
Microsoft standard the Xbox one would
think that that cannot be it appreciates
if it's being designed with PC in mind
first okay Halo Wars 2 was the same way
that's fine thanks but no so okay well
we got next
all right Gears of War 5 all right now
if you told me that we were getting
another Gears of War game before we be
getting the next halo I think called you
crazy but look here we are right so
Gears of War 5 looks like they're taking
the franchise in a different direction
is the protagonist I've long argued that
she was the most interesting of the
bunch in Gears she's dope let me cuz yo
they did the fake outdoor cuz in the
beginning they had two dead body so I'm
like oh they got JD oh they got Marcus
and did you slowly see them we don't
know who is it it's dead we don't know
but whatever it is Kate's on the mission
of vengeance looks like we got some
serious melee combat yeah
swinging around suddenly and it looks
like they're bringing some more survival
horror elements in with like the
clambering the odd this figure that's at
the enemies I love it
it's fantastic so let's see it loves
them we got Ori or in the world The Wiz
beautiful you know I don't think there's
really much you can say about that it's
heartwarming it's fantastic crackdown 3
ok let me jump on that I'm be honest
like I didn't expect much coming in and
I'm gonna say it looked way better than
past showing better than ever before
hand I think given what we've heard
about the development of that game it
might be the best the best it's going to
be right although is that can we play as
Terry Crews can we collect orbs power up
blow up stuff destructions there all
right we're good so February is getting
dangerous yeah 30 seconds
Japanese games on stage and run
fantastic third-party support fantastic
and closing on cyberpunk to me
theatrical good yeah overall rating nine
out of ten nine out of ten man 15 the
Lords Damon I love the show I thought
they had to deliver the back was against
the wall 10 and that was it mister the
laws of flap enough it's a little recap
wrong I'm going